good morning everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is scp-999 object class
safe special containment procedures
scp-999 is allowed to freely roam the
facility should it desire to but
otherwise must stay in this pen either
between 8:00 p.m. or 9:00 p.m. for
sleeping or during emergency lock downs
for its own safety subject is not
allowed out of its pen at night or off
facility grounds at any time pen is to
be kept clean and food replaced twice
daily all personnel are allowed inside a
cp9 99s holding area but only if they
are not assigned to other tasks at the
time or if they are on a break subject
is to be played with when bored and
spoken to in a calm non-threatening tone
description scp-999 appears to be a
large amorphous gelatinous mass of
translucent orange slime weighing about
54 kilograms with a consistency similar
to that of peanut butter subjects size
and shape is easily malleable and can
change shape at will though when at rest
scp-999 becomes a rounded oblate dome
roughly 2 metres wide and 1 metre in
height the surface of scp-999 consists
of a thin transparent membrane similar
to that of an animal cell roughly 0.5
centimeters thick and is highly elastic
allowing scp-999 to flatten portions of
its body up to two centimeters thin this
surface is also hydrophobic although
scp-999 can willfully absorb liquids the
rest of scp-999 s bonnie is filled with
a viscous orange substance of unknown
chemical makeup though it is capable of
digesting organic materials with ease
subjects temperament is best described
as playful and doglike when approached
scp-999 will often react with
overwhelming elation slithering over to
the nearest person and leaping upon them
hugging them with a pair of pseudopods
while nuzzling the person's face with a
third pseudopod all the while emitting
high-pitched gurgling and cooing noises
the surface of scp-999 emits a pleasing
odor that differs with whomever it is
interacting with recorded sense include
chocolate fresh laundry bacon roses and
play-doh
simply touching a-c-p 999 surface causes
an immediate mild euphoria which
intensifies the longer one is exposed to
scp-999 and lasts long after separation
from the creature subjects favorite
activity is tickle wrestling often by
completely enveloping a person from the
neck down and tickling them until asked
to stop though it does not always
immediately comply with this request
though injuries may occur scp-999 has
never been found to purposefully attempt
to harm others and will immediately back
away and contract its body into a
quivering mound while gurgling in a
similar manner to a whimpering dog
seemingly apologizing for hurting
someone on accident while the creature
will interact with anyone it seems to
have a special interest in those who are
unhappy or hurt in any way persons
suffering from crippling depression or
PTSD for example have reported having a
far more positive outlook on life after
multiple interactions with scp-999 the
possibility of manufacturing
antidepressants from a-c-p 999 slime is
currently being discussed
in addition to its playful behavior
scp-999 seems to love all animals
especially humans refusing to eat any
meat and even risking its own life to
save others
on one occasion leaping in front of a
person to take a bullet fired at them
subjects intellect is still up for
debate though its behavior is infantile
it seems to understand human speech and
most modern technology including guns
scp-999 s diet consists entirely of
candy and sweets with M&Ms and Necco
wafers being its favorites it's eating
methods are similar to those of an
amoeba addendum scp-999 a reminder to
all staff scp-999 is not to consume
caffeinated soft drinks of any kind last
week someone gave us CP $9.99 a can of
cola along with its usual breakfast not
only was it literally bouncing off the
walls for half an hour the carbonation
made scp-999 visibly queasy afterwards
and it refused to move or eat the rest
of the day scp-999 has thankfully
recovered since but the staff member in
question has been reprimanded
dr. addendum scp-999 b the following is
a report from an experiment in which
scp-682 is exposed to scp-999 in the
hopes that it will curb the creatures on
this side alrea scp-999 is released into
a CP 682 s containment area scp-999
immediately slithers towards scp-682
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
scp-999 moves in front of scp-682
jumping up and down in a doglike manner
while calling out in a high-pitched
squealing noise scp-682 immediately
steps on a CP 999 completely flattening
scp-999 observers were about to abort
the experiment when scp-682 started
talking again scp-999 can be seen
crawling up from between scp-682 toes up
along its side and around its neck where
it clings on and begins gently nuzzling
with its suitor pod a wide grin slowly
spreads across scp-682 s face
[Music]
scp-682 repeats the word happy for
several minutes
laughing occasionally before escalating
into nonstop laughter now as laughter
continues scp-682 rolls around on its
back
slamming its tail upon the floor with
dangerous force scp-682 and scp-999
continue the tickle fight
until scp-682 finally wears down and
appears to fall asleep with what would
appear to be a smile on its face after
15 minutes with no activity two d-class
personnel enter the room to retrieve
scp-999 when scp-999 is removed scp-682
immediately wakes up and unleashes an
unidentifiable wave of energy from its
body or the while laughing manically all
persons within the waves range collapse
into crippling fits of laughter allowing
a CB 682 to escape and slaughter all in
its path meanwhile scp-999 quickly
rescues as many persons as it can taking
them to a safe place to recover from
scp-682 z' laughter wave while agents
suppress Sandri contain scp-682 despite
the tragedy that scp-682 had brought
upon the facility as CP 999 as a not
showing any fear towards the creature
and in fact has made gestures suggesting
it wants to play with scp-682 again the
682 however has stated that feculent
little can't open died
[Music]
memo from dr. Cooper while the test was
unsuccessful and ended in tragedy that
had to be the funniest thing I have ever
seen I never thought I'd see the day
when I would regard scp-682 as cute
please send me a copy of the security
tapes as soon as possible
I'm just gonna end this lecture with a
piece of advice don't try and use 999 as
some kind of therapy it doesn't work and
you just end up getting banned from it
spent it happened to my friend turns out
something that eats M&Ms and Necco
wafers doesn't really taste that good
when it's coming in or feel that good
when it's coming out I know too much
information sorry it's been a long week
anyway thank you for listening if indeed
you still are and you are all dismissed
good bye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to the reclusive extrovert geum's Sabah
Kathryn June's Pablo ice 917 Karim a la
shmoop
Justin de Pury kuma Trevor W peg white
crew NJ Vujic Bryson Bailey my archive
curator neck tie verbal Burlington the
cot and courts 563 if you would like a
special thank you at the end of each of
my videos on some other cool stuff as
well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
Volgin thank you
[Music]
you